combats démarrés avec cette affaire qui
fait grand bruit c'est une employée
d'une enseigne de la grande distribution
qui a été par don licencié pour avoir
refusé de travailler le dimanche
seignosse vous en dit plus le courrier
est arrivé le 26 avril au domicile de
christelle la faute grave en question
c'est une insubordination en clair son
refus de travailler le dimanche écrit
noir sur blanc dans sa lettre de
licenciement
je veux pas travailler dimanche donc
c'est pour ça je suis licencié au bout
de 18 ans de boîte
l'enseigne communique à fond sur cette
ouverture dominicale pour se démarquer
de la concurrence
mais la communication sur le sujet avec
ses propres salariés semblent avoir été
plus légère sur le contrat de travail
il n'est nullement mentionné qu'elle
doit travailler en réalité le dimanche
l'inspection du travail semblent sur la
même longueur d'onde christelle soutenu
par la cftc pourrait porter l affaire
devant les prud'hommes de saint malo
étonnamment sur plus de 200 salariés
seuls deux ont fait valoir leur refus du
travail dominical mais parce qu'il ait
mis la pression
vous êtes s'étaient passées dehors alors
vous l'avez entend des deux employé
aurait été licencié pour ce motif la
direction du magasin n'a pas répondu aux
sollicitations des journalistes
mais elle rappelle dans sa lettre de
licenciement que l'employé avait déjà
accepté de travailler quatre dimanches
en 2018 ce qui donnerait à l'explication
pour lesquels pour laquelle ils se
seraient mis dans cette situation qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
timmy mois m non c'est vraiment
dégueulasse cette histoire il n'y a pas
d'autre mot à celle terme comme
l'éloignement ça maintenant je suis
blessée parce que cette femme a
travaillé 18 ans dans un supermarché au
public c'est un travail qui reste
difficile et au bout de 18 ans alors
qu'on nous dit bah c'est finalement sur
le bénévolat
elle a accepté donc finalement frais
qu'elle accepte tout le temps je suis
désolé parce que c'est seulement fait
comprendre l'enseignant dix ans comme
elle a accepté en 2010 8 4 dimanche
pourquoi elle accepterait pas bien que
la loi n'est pas claire et que
finalement ce millefeuille administratif
et qu'on n'a jamais tranché obligatoire
on fait des amendements oui non aux
contrats oui ça va passer et au final ce
qui est encore plus triste dans cette
histoire c'est que avec la loi pénicaud
et bien finalement le plafond des
indemnités est limité et donc cette
femme avec ses 18 ans d ancienneté va
toucher une tout petite partie de
l'indemnité donc c'est un calcul assez
facile d'autant plus lorsqu'on sait que
sur on entend 200 salariés dont on
refuse et je pense qu'ils auraient pu la
laisser tranquille le dimanche si elle a
décidé que c'était pour la cellule
familiale parce qu'en semaine on
travaille on veut se retrouver peut-être
moins parlé à la mère
l'europe se reposer le dimanche elle a
droit de refuser c'est scandaleux
jean-michel je vois dire non de la tête
je suis pas du tout d'accord
parce que là on n'est pas en train de
parler du cas particulier de cette dame
il va être tranché par les prud'hommes
donc on saura ce qui va se passer c'est
une affaire de contrat de travail
ce que je veux dire c'est je veux parler
d'une façon générale à propos du travail
de dimanche
toi tu te places du côté du travailleur
de celui qui travaillent le dimanche
moi je place du côté de l'utilisateur il
ya beaucoup de gens qui sont ravis de
pouvoir faire leurs courses de dimanche
et qui ont droit de faire leurs courses
le dimanche
alors que ce soit volontaire peut-être
ce qu'il veut s'il y en a qui veulent ne
pas travailler le dimanche
mais d'un autre côté la société est en
train de changer le boulot ils changent
partout il ya plein de suppressions
d'emploi à cause justement des nouvelles
technologies des nouvelles façons de
travailler donc faut bien trouver des
remodelages de la société tu vas pas
accroché à un truc là c'est vraiment le
mal français on veut pas que ça change
il faut que rien aujourd'hui c'est une
parade parce que effectivement là c'est
à l'association dont je vois là mais
peut-être que si elles travaillent le
dimanche matin alors à deux heures de
plus ou un peu plus d'argent et
peut-être qui renouera qui ont pas le
droit
mais il faut accepter les changements
caroline jour vous aussi vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec qui avec jean-michel ou
avec mais je suis choqué par les propos
de jean michel et feignant bien sûr
fille combien de temps tu as pas
travailler ni un samedi un dimanche veut
dire parfois la loi des choses
depuis combien de temps je doublais ats
je travaille 6 jours sur 7 minimum
handicap dimanche apparemment
apparemment tu vois toi tu te trompes
moi je suis à fond derrière christelle
je trouve qu'elle a raison de se battre
je pense qu'elle devrait normalement
emporté gain de cause sur ce sur ce cas
là mais même son papa que de son quart
sur le travail des diamants sur général
vous vous dites travail le dimanche je
veux dire que ce soit sur la base du
volontariat trouve ça très bien que ce
soit inscrit dans la loi d'avoir ce cas
là je serai hors la loi je suis désolé
on n'a pas à forcer quelqu'un à
travailler le dimanche alors que
culturellement inscrits au lancement
s'est inscrit en tout cas dans la
culture d'un pays et je suis désolée
elle a raison de se battre
vivement qu'il fait que l'europe c'est
facile lorsque jean-michel dit il faut
aussi que j'allais dire le monde dans le
monde de l'entreprise s'adapte à la
mutation au fait que
et donc à ce moment-là on évolue et
qu'on travaille aussi le dimanche
peut-être pour récupérer le lundi ou le
marais là dans ce cas là c'est quoi
l'accord mois si on travaille la nuit
son travail soit passée loin aujourd'hui
qui dit qu'on doit travailler dans les
zones qu'il n'ya pas à se soumettre et
ce truc de danse subordination est
insupportable elle fait encore ce
qu'elle fait elle a raison elle avait
voulu non absorbé les sondages arriver
imposer ça tu vas gagner du temps je
suis à jarry au marché le dimanche
eh bien il ya des combats sans que le
match de l'année d'avant avec soleil
sont les assises en laissant un vide on
se plaint du matin au soir que les
centres-villes meurent parce qu'on nous
les centres commerciaux
et ça c'est déjà une marche et une
énorme et peu importe et quand on parle
de la société s'adapte désolé les
centres commerciaux sont ouverts jusqu'à
22 heures
on est jusqu'à 22 heures pour aller
faire ses courses on n'a pas besoin du
centre commercial le dimanche matin pour
aller acheter la baguette ou peu importe
donc à carreaux soutenir cette dame est
faux si on veut ne pas travailler
dimanche
on travaille pas d'accord on a quand
même des lois et des règles en france je
comprends pas pourquoi on se dispute là
dessus il ya trois termes juridiques
le premier c'est quand tu travailles
dans une entreprise non alimentaire
c'est-à-dire en ameublement des
bricolages tu es obligé de travailler
dimanche si ton employeur te le demande
lorsque tu travaille dans une entreprise
alimentaire ou les aliments ne sont pas
produits sur place très souvent c'est
les épiceries les boulangeries et c'est
là tu dois travailler jusqu'à 13h et au
delà si tu es dans une zone 1 du temps
une zone qu'on appelle ça internationale
c'est à dire les gares les aéroports là
où il ya des gens à l'international qui
sont à l'intérieur donc je vois pas
pourquoi ce débat oui c'est triste pour
cette dame mais ce sont les lois se sait
sous le régime de maquereaux et on ne
peut pas débattre des mois on doit
respecter les lois c'est qu'on passe et
fonçait là seulement macro il ya aussi à
notre problème on sait très bien qu'il
ya beaucoup de chômage à l'heure
actuelle en france qu'il faut retrouver
des poches de d'emploi famille annoncé
sa chance à cette réalité ce serait
partie fille ciel de dire on va le
problème de le des chemins rené
l'exemple des états unis tous les petits
boulots qui existe aux états unis
décelant étudiant nommé au quai il va
craquer face aux états unis les gens
crèvent la dalle
ok c'est ton choix je prévois une grande
enseigne et qui n'est là que pour faire
du profit ne force pas ses salariés qui
auront peur de dire non à dire oui parce
que c'est quand même si elle en est
super on va quand même y aller c'est
parce qu'ils ont peur de perdre leur
emploi
donc il faut des gens comme christelle
pour ouvrir la voie pour leur montrer
que bah ouais eh bien il faut un petit
moment de les sortir les crocs
et dire on tenait pas des animaux en
fait sens les gens tu leur dis d'être
hors la loi c'est parler de la loi
là je vous explique on a une société
moderne on te dis moi même d'obliger
quelqu'un à faire quelque chose on te
dis que c'est possible de le faire
là je t'ai dit on ne parle pas de ce cas
particulier s'il ya un contact travail
qui justifiait pas travailler le
dimanche
elle va gagner mais on a posé la
question de téléspectateurs justement
sur le non pas le cas précis de cette
jeune femme et sur le travail le
dimanche
est ce que vous êtes pour ou est-ce que
vous êtes contre 7 partager mais pour
tout de même à 41% comptera 59 ça reste
encore la majorité continue à réagir à
nous donner votre sentiment sur ce sur
ce sujet qui visiblement fait beaucoup
réagir nos chroniqueurs et j'imagine
vous aussi devant la télé en tout cas
pour travailler le dimanche il faut
surtout que vos employés soient
réveillés plutôt bien même
[Musique]
martin ou tard rien n'était mais
vraiment comme si de rien n'était